[Musique]
sainte soulle a toujours été une valeur
sûre achetez samsung s'est acheté une
maîtrise technologique un réel savoir
faire c'est pour ça que ça me semble une
place de leader international qui
partagent cette place un coup samsung un
coup apple joue un peu au ping pong l'un
et l'autre mais surtout les deux une
place de choix
mais en 2018 la règle du jeu a changé on
a assisté à une montée en puissance de
huawei à l'émergence de nouveaux géants
et une montée en puissance de fabricants
chinois au pot xiaomi one + et plein
d'autres
du coup les cartes ont complètement été
redistribuées quelle place une marque
comme 500 peut-elle garde et avoir alors
que le marché est en pleine mutation et
qui aimeraient agressivité une vraie
concurrence qui fait rage sur tous les
fronts et même google s'y est mis et
arrivé en france avec le pixel 3 mpixels
whitesell est-ce qu'on peut assister à
un changement complet est ce que les
cartes vont être complètement
redistribuées est ce qu'on peut voir un
déclin
une mort peut-être pas mais en tout cas
un déclin de marques comme samsung ou
pourquoi pas de marques comme apple
commence et marques peuvent et doivent
réagir pour continuer à exister
ce qui est sûr c'est que marques comme
samsung doit continuer d'innover pour
garder une place fort dans le gard
d'entrée aux gammes appareil photo à
ouverture variable excellente qualité en
photo sur la gamme note un s pen
bluetooth pourquoi encore plein d'autres
usages des performances accrues et puis
toujours une
les usages en 2018 est encore plus en
2019 vont se diriger vers des grands
écrans pour du multimédia pour regarder
des vidéos sur youtube sur netflix pour
regarder les réseaux sociaux est
justement par extension darif pour le
deuxième usage qui est la prise de
photos vidéos pour le partage sur les
réseaux sociaux
snap charrette instagram et puis tous
les autres c'est vraiment des usages qui
sont plus en plus fort et c'est là
puisqu'ils constructeurs se battent pour
avoir les plus grands les plus beaux
écrans et les meilleurs appareils photo
en 2018 samsung a vraiment travaillé à
accentuer son milieu de gamme au début
d'année on a eu le a8 et a8 plus on a eu
lieu à 6 à 6 plus le à 7 le à neuf mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit suffisant
par rapport à la force de frappe de la
concurrence l'adn de samsung l'adn de la
marque c'est l'innovation alors que
certains concurrents se contentent de
copier être positionné des smartphones
qui sont un peu des pâles copies pas sur
tous les modèles
mais c'est pas mal de modèles mais vous
aussi qui les voit sur teknologik n'est
pas uniquement l'apanage de samsung
huawei par exemple avec son triple
module photo sont tes 20 trop et sur le
mail d'un pro un appareil photo qui est
extraordinaire qui en tout cas
aujourd'hui
probablement avec le s9 plus et 99
meilleur photophone de l'année 2018 au
pot également que le finepix quand ils
sont arrivés en france au carrousel du
louvre vraiment prouvé qu'il était
extrêmement performant pour proposer des
smartphones complètement innovant
samsung va continuer d'innover en 2019
avec son smartphone à écran pliable ils
ont déjà présenté montré en tout cas pas
en catimini samsung galaxy x galaxy s
n'est pas le nom exact on voit que
samsung va continuer tout cas faire une
vraie démonstration force d'une vraie
bataille que se livrent pour être le
premier à sortir la première innovation
pour faire parler lui la royauté sortie
a pas très longtemps un smartphone à
écran payal qui en tout cas ne semble
pas être particulièrement abouti
aujourd'hui en tout cas ils l'ont sortie
ils l'ont fait avant les autres alors
que samsung depuis des années
on va sortir un smartphone à écran
pigalle travaille dessus depuis 2011 on
est les premiers à sortir et là sont
faits d'avancé sur la dernière ligne
droite en 2019 un summum pour également
repositionné son milieu de gamme avec la
gamme galaxy m
pour y avoir le galaxy elle vint pour
avoir une encoche en forme de goutte
d'eau un design relativement connu avec
un capteur d'empreintes digitales
positionné au dos de l'appareil double
module photo 13 + 5 mégapixels et
surtout pour avoir un écran lcd de 6
pouces et j'ai du mal à y croire j'ai du
mal à comprendre si c'est réellement ce
qui se passe
samsung vous avez fait votre force avec
les écrans super amoled des qualités
complètement irréprochable se positionne
aujourd'hui sur un milieu de gamme avec
un écran lcd
ça serait quand même relativement
bizarre je comprends permet de se
positionner face à la concurrence fiche
technique face à fiche technique mais au
final est-ce que vous risqueriez pas
c'est réellement le cas de perdre un peu
votre adn des os pour avoir un exil au
7883 giga de ram surtout une énorme
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures ce
qui au final sereine il en perd heures
au dessus de la batterie du galaxy note
9 avoir en 2019 si ce produit sort est
ce que ça serait suffisant pour que
samsung continue à avoir une place de
choix dans milieu de gamme ils sont
encore très forts dans le haut de gamme
mais des flagships killer comme le one +
6 taylor fait franchement l'ombre des
smartphones qui ont une fiche technique
assez incroyable et surtout beaucoup
moins cher dans le milieu de gamme des
marques comme chez omis ou comme au nord
ne font strictement aucun cadeau à
samsung et dans notre île gamme c'est
très compliqué face à la concurrence
chinoise propose des smartphones très
intéressant très innovant et à des
tarifs extrêmement bas c'est une vrai
dire tranché et on sait pas réellement
qui va sortir vainqueurs mais j'adore
samsung j'adore leurs produits qui sont
vraiment moteur d'innovation et je me
demande si à force de voir se
positionner face à la concurrence
qu'est-ce que tu ailles avoir une
uniformisation des smartphones un
produit face à notre produit un
smartphone qui répondent aux smartphones
au final on a beaucoup de produits ils
sont quasiment tous identiques et il
n'ya pas réellement de grand intérêt et
du coup on pourrait imaginer que seuls
les flagships deviendrait réellement
intéressant et un milieu de gamme dans
l'entrée de gamme qui se passait pas
grand chose mais d'un côté comment
innover comment ne pas se faire doubler
alors que tout fuite en permanence ce
soit dans les usines au niveau du
marketing on sent qu'il ya des fuites de
tous les côtés et c'est compliqué pour
une marque de garder le secret sur une
innovation alors qu'on sait quasiment
tue quelques semaines voire quelques
mois avant la présentation officielle
d'un smartphone pour moi et que je suis
spectateur c'est sûr que c'est
formidable
il ya tellement marque tellement de
produits les produits sur tout le temps
ça l'espèce de bouillon de culture au
final on a toujours des choses à vous
dire sur les choses à vous présenter et
à vous expliquer mais pour un industriel
comme samsung comme beaucoup d'autres
doit être relativement compliqué à gérer
c'est un vrai champ de bataille et au
final je me demande quelle sera l'issue
est-ce que des marques vont finir par
tomber est ce qu'un géants comme samsung
peut chuter
c'est difficile à dire aujourd'hui est
notre cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je ne
le souhaite absolument pas samsung
j'aime beaucoup votre philosophie aux
innovations et j'espère que ça va durer
encore longtemps
[Musique]